- What do you remember?
- I remember
getting in the bathtub.
- You do remember
I remember
not being drunk enough
and then being real drunk.
Alright, you wanna be on national TV?
Fancy Ray died a month after we shot this
so I'm curious to see how
disrespectful I was with him
cause we hated him.
(laughs)
Can I tell my story?
(dog barks)
This is not helpful.
Comedy Central is not
appreciative of your barks.
(dog growls)
- He barks a lot.
- Fancy Ray cost 700 dollars to die.
Crazy.
Hoo
- [Derek] How do you feel?
- Horrible
And awesome.
- You got real drunk.
- Mm hmm.
- [Derek] You wanna
take a cold bath with me
after I scrub my balls?
- I've got at least two bathing suits,
should I put em on to get in the tub?
Oh no.
- Were you, like, I'm
gonna try and get Derek
to get in the bathtub, before?
- No, not at all, you would think I was
cause I kept coming on to you.
- You don't have the balls
to get in the tub with me.
(laughs)
- [Dirk] Oh, I do.
- I'm like a creepy old
gay producer in Hollywood
(laughs)
like I got a casting couch
with young actors coming in.
And this bathing suit
is like my conservative,
public bathing suit.
So people don't walk up
to me at pools and say,
"Are you Jay Ryznar?"
- Cause your dick's so long?
- [Jay] No, well I've got a
very moderately-sized dick.
- A moderate size?
- It's a mullet wig
that I thought was more
reasonable but it's a cartoon
mullet wig unfortunately.
(laughs)
- [Dirk] What's cartoon
about it, it looks real?
- No, it doesn't look
real, it's too bangy.
(both men laugh)
- I wish it looked more like Bob Seger
but it looks more like Joe Dirt.
(both men laugh)
- I like drunk me a lot.
- I'm thinking about my Dad.
I'm thinking about my Mom, so proud.
(both men laugh)
This episode ain't makin it
(mumbles)
- Then you just like rip on me
(laughs)
for being a terrible host
cause I won't kiss you.
(both men laugh)
- Shittiest host of any
Comedy Central show ever.
- Oh, the best would be just
me, just making out with you?
That would be the best?
(laughs)